hello
hello nice to meet you dr roland shearer
is head of the new desert flower center
sir nighttime is hoping he can change
her life
as a child she was a victim of genital
mutilation
her clitoris was removed with a razor
blade
i want to be complicated person yeah
what they cutting us i want to get back
the surgeon performs complicated
operations to reconstruct patients
genitalia
the surgery is free it's part of a
campaign against the ritual of female
genital circumcision
it's an age-old tradition that's been
practiced in families for generations
over thousands of years
this operation is to help women who have
undergone circumcision to reverse it
it's not about actively encouraging them
we're just offering something that was
unavailable until now
the project would not exist without this
woman waris deary
the former model from somalia has fought
against female genital mutilation for
over 16 years she herself was also a
victim
a clip from a movie about her life was
shown at the opening for the center this
week
even after so many years the pain of her
trauma is still raw
all of those beautiful women
who's been destroyed
if they can have something back
to know
because they don't even give the chance
to know what it feels like to be a woman
so if you can have little bit of
something
that you can
give a joy
to be a woman again
then i thank you i salute you doctors
but getting to this stage has not been
easy which is something fedumer corn
knows well
she's been helping women affected by
genital mutilation in germany for almost
20 years
anonymously of course
families of the women are not allowed to
know
faduma was just seven when her clitoris
and inner labia were removed with a
razor blade
she suffered a severe infection which
she is still affected by to this day her
hands will be stiff forever
this
and the way it's linked to some idea of
mysticism makes young girls want to
undergo circumcision
we think we'll be flawed if we don't
because that's what we're taught
when in fact
the opposite is true
is talking to a young woman
she wants to remain anonymous for fear
of her family's reaction
reverse circumcision wasn't her first
priority
but after lengthy discussion with
fadumakorn she agreed to have pelvic
surgery a major step
i feel much freer
i can move easily and do sports every
day
i can do what i want and it's all okay
i can finally go to the toilet without
problems that's the best of all
before it would take me two hours to
urinate because it would only come out
drop by drop it was difficult
but the young somalian woman is angry at
the way she was lied to
that she was subjected to such a
horrific procedure and endured so much
unnecessary pain
my mother told me we were going into
town to buy a treat i thought i'd be
getting something nice to eat
but then when we arrived at a house
where there was a woman and then some
other woman appeared
and they held me down and cut me
female genital mutilation is officially
banned in many african countries but
according to the world health
organization the ritual procedure is
carried out every 11 seconds
it's supposedly a guarantee of chastity
and sexual loyalty
most women who undergo reverse
circumcision do so in secret or they
insist the reason is purely medical even
in germany
doctors who perform the operation in
munich issue a certificate that states
the surgery was performed for medical
reasons rather than personal
even so it's hard for parents to accept
that their daughter whom they went to
great lengths to have circumcised and
paid money for the procedure would have
it reversed
especially if she's unmarried
among the goals of a new desert flower
center in berlin is to help young women
like sinead de missa cope with the
consequences of female genital
mutilation and to give them back
ownership of their bodies
it's a brave step that hopefully many
more women will dare to take